VEGAS BACK IN OCTOBER.
NUGENT-HOPKINS AND J.T. MILLER
THE LEAGUE FROM THE BACK BET99..
>> Jack: HOW ABOBO
AWESOME.COUVER
PLAYING OFTEN WITH THE SEDIN
CANUCK ALL YEAR.
HE'S BEEN CONSISTENT AND JUST A
BEAUTIFUL ENTRY INN COME IN
HERE
ANOTHER SAVE BY KOSKINEN ON
GARLAND.OT ERASED BY KULAK.
PETAN...CLUB, THEY
PROBABLY NEEDED ANOTHER 10, 15
HOCKEY CLUBS AND ARE AN
>> Louie:GOOD ENTRY IN TO THE Z.
EVANDER KANE WAS IN THAT SECOND
PERIOD.
HE STARTS THINGS OFFFF
TEAM.ON THE SEASON.
KULAK PUCK.
HE'S SEEING EVERYTHING, MAKING
THOSE TYPES OF SAVES AT 6' Jack.
KASSIAN WITH GOOD
SO NOW BARRIRI
McLEOD WITH NINE GOALS.
IF HE GETS 10, THAT WOULD BE 11.
BARRELLING DOWN OFF TO
>> Louie: WHAT ACTION.
A COUPLELER TRIED TO
GO BACK DOOR FOR BOESER AND THAT
WAS OFF TARGETET
LOLO
AWAY SO QUICKLY.
GOES TO THE OUTSIDE, COMES TO
THE INSIDE, A LITTLE FAKE BRINGS
IT BACK AND FOREHAND
BLOCKER SIDE AND KOSKINEN PUT
THE PAD DOWN.
>> Jack: MILLER, 9 OF 22 FOR TH
HE STILL RINGS THE BAR.
SCORES!